We're finding ourselves at a very
exciting moment with the Skywalker saga
coming to an end.
We're at a place of
what's next for Star Wars.
one of the things we've always done
is be able to
use our franchise platforms to explore
the creative potential of the Star Wars
galaxy.
And so what if publishing was
more of an incubation. We've all done
lots of storytelling but this is unique
and really special.
It's the secret history the
galaxy yeah it goes way back to the
beginning of Star Wars.
For over a thousand generations. The Jedi knights were the guardians of peace and Justice.
a line that we've
been hearing since 1977 and we thought
you know what does that look like?
It is a golden age where there's
much more
peace and calm in the galaxy so we're
calling it the High Republic
The description that we've used for the Jedi
of this era is that they are the jedi
knights of the round table.
But Star Wars isn't just about Jedi
and we will
tell stories of new smugglers new
scoundrels new bounty hunters
The Threat and the tension really comes from the
Republic's borders.
Because the Republic does not extend
from one side of the
galaxy to the other.
It's a bit of a wild west new frontier
we see a different
kind of Jedi that patrols the frontiers
and is more of a Texas Ranger.
We're now bringing in concept artists
illustrators and visualists the same
way that you would when you're making a movie
we even had Ian Mckay come down and just do
sketch after sketch for us.
When you have the guy
who designed the look for Darth Maul
sketching Jedi for you. Doesn't get
any cooler than this.
It gives us the ability to tell vast interconnected stories
across multiple years.
There will be a core group of heroes
that will expand over time. There will be villains.
Our main villain are the group called the
Nhil
we kind of like to refer to them as space vikings.
Their motto is you can't
take it with you but we can take it from you.
Our story starts with what we're calling
the great disaster
it wouldn't be Star Wars without
adventure and there's definitely a
series of events that that won't spin
the galaxy into a dangerous new
direction and it'll give the opportunity
for Heroes to rise up.
The cool thing about this is that
there's going to be a
story for every Star Wars fan.
What scares the Jedi?
and that made us all go...ooh!
Something Wicked This Way Comes
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my breakdown of the Star
Wars High Republic trailer which is
starting later this year it's sort of
the beginning of what's going to be the
next big phase of Star Wars storytelling
all the movies the Disney Plus series
and all the publishing stuff if you're
new to my channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos this is going to be
in addition to all the mandalorian
season 2 stuff that's happening this
year and all the other Disney Plus stuff
is already in production we'll just
break this down top 5 style starting
with number 5 what is Star Wars High
Republic well as the pull quote from
obi-wan Kenobi says for over a thousand
generations the Jedi Knights were the
guardians of peace and justice in the
Old Republic before the dark times
before the Empire well this is Star Wars
sort of shifting its focus into the past
we all kind of assumed that they would
try some Old Republic stories at a
certain point this is obviously during a
slightly different time period they're
calling this somewhere between two
hundred two hundred and thirty years
before the events of the modern era so
we're talking about a much younger
version of Yoda who would still be
pretty old Yoda said that he'd been
training Jedi's since he was around a
hundred years old so that means that's
also around the time he became a Jedi
Master but age is pretty relative for
Master Yoda they slipped in some concept
art of a younger version of Yoda into
this trailer too you may have spotted it
so there are a couple Easter eggs for
Yoda stuff even though they didn't focus
on it too much for the most part the
early stuff that they're going to start
dropping in August is mostly introducing
a bunch of new characters because
obviously Yoda is like the one common
denominator the one person who was
around to see all this happen but most
of the humanoid characters live normal
lifespans so most of these people would
all be dead and gone by the time the
prequels begin the reason why they're
choosing to call it the High Republic
era is to differentiate it from the Old
Republic so Old Republic is thousands of
years ago this is hundreds of years ago
and they're calling it the height of the
Republic is in during this period the
Jedi Order was at the height of his
power and level of respect within the
Republic but the Republic itself didn't
extend from one end of the galaxy to the
other so their borders are smaller and
there's a lot of other syndicates and
factions within the galaxy that also
holds a lot of power like we talked
about the ancient Mandalorians having a
lot of power so also address that tube
because
they did give us a little bit of a
teaser for the history of the war
between the Jedi and the Mandalorians
but that's not what's happening during
the period of the High Republic.
The songs of eons past tell of battles
between Mandalore the great
and an order of sorcerors called Jedi
that fought with such powers
they did reveal who the
first new main villains are going to be
during this period they didn't say
they'd be the only villains and they
didn't talk a whole lot about what's
going on with the Sith because this is
still during the prime time rule of two
era of the Sith so the obvious follow-up
question is number four what's going
on with all the new Star Wars movies
that have been confirmed in new Disney
Plus series that they're making right
now the official release dates for the
next couple of Star Wars movies are
December 16 2022 December 20th 2024 and
then December 18 2026 basically same old
Star Wars movie scheduled starting in
2022 except that it's not supposed to be
a trilogy they've said that they're
moving away from the trilogy model and
they're just going to start doing
standalone movies with the option that
if something becomes really popular it
might become a trilogy the way they're
talking about the High Republic era is
that it's sort of an incubator for
stories I think the strongest of these
stories potential to become Disney Plus
series but because they're just starting
out it's probably going to take them a
couple years to find out what sticks
because they just started exploring this
new era in Star Wars history there was
the rumored Old Republic movie that went
into development we haven't heard about
that much since it was announced that
could become a Disney Plus series too so
if you hear them talking about Knights
of the Old Republic Disney Plus series
that's what they're referring to there's
Kevin Feige Star Wars movie that they
announced we don't know what that's
going to be or what era it's going to be
set during there's the new SIF movie set
on x ago before the events of the new
trilogy that they just announced a
couple days ago but the Hollywood trades
are also reporting that that could
become a Disney Plus series I think it
just depends on how strong the pitch
winds up being there's Tyco whitey DS
rumoured Star Wars movie he just jokes
about that when people ask him about it
trying to pretend like it's not a real
thing there's also a bunch of spin-offs
for the Mandalorian series they just
announced but they didn't say which time
period that would be set during some
will probably be set during the past
some will probably set during the future
it even though it seems like a
no-brainer like eventually they should
do a baby Yoda movie they have not
talked about doing a baby yoda movie yet
because obviously he is the future of
the Jedi Order someone to watch the next
800 to 900 years of Jedi history unfold
in the galaxy number three who are the
new main characters what are the Jedi
doing during this High Republic era and
who are the new main villains
they've only revealed a couple of the
characters names but the very first
project is coming from Charles Soule is
called the light of the Jedi and it's
going to sort of world build and explain
what's going on it's going to be the intro
to the high republic era I don't know
how to pronounce his name but he said
that the Wookiee Jedi's name is spelled
like this and this lady in the front is
named a bar Kris they're saying the
story of the hybrid public begins with
the event called the great disaster some
big cataclysmic event they just say that
the new group of villains is called the
Nile and they're kind of like space
Vikings so it's not necessarily the Sith
but then obviously they end with that
teaser what are the Jedi afraid of we're
going to explore that what are the Jedi
afraid of mostly the Sith so I think
that implies that we will eventually see
the rise of the Sith or the rule of two
continued during this era but it is
still during the rule of two so there's
no giant group of sits out there hiding
but number two what's going on with
Yoda during this period in his life we
see couple screen grabs of a young
version of Yoda or a younger version of
Yoda because he be in his 700th instead
of being in his eight or nine hundreds
but like Yoda has said he'd been
training Jedi since he was around a
hundred years old that's when he became
a Jedi Master so around this time he
would have already become the senior
member of the Jedi Council at the height
of its power and influence within the
Republic so even though Yoda was at his
most powerful once he became a force
ghost just based on the mythology in the
way that the force works this is Yoda at
the height of his power within the
physical world but number one how
will these High Republic era stories
that they're starting to release this
August going to help set up the new Star
Wars movies and new Star Wars Disney
Plus series for the most part they're
just saying that the early stuff is
going to be an incubator for potential
ideas to mine for a new movie and TV
projects so I think it's more likely
that we would wind up eventually seeing
a high republic Disney Plus series
before we see a high republic movie just
because the risk is so much lower but
it's probably going to be a couple years
before we find out about that just
because they want to see how the
published
stuff does first then they'll start
doubling down on this era in history but
in terms of moving Star Wars movies into
the past this is in addition to all the
rumored Old Republic stuff or Knights of
the Old Republic that they talked about
before if the timeline sounds kind of
confusing don't worry I'll address the
timeline when each new Star Wars Disney
Plus series in the next couple of years
starts and where it fits in everyone
post all your reactions to this hybrid
public stuff in the comments below let
me know what you're most excited about
there'll be more Mandalorian season to
stuff happening really soon in my Star
Wars the Clone Wars season 7 episode 2
video will post this Friday just like
normal
brand new Star Wars Clone Wars episodes
every Friday everyone click here for my
brand new Mandalorian season 2 preview
video and click here for my brand new
Star Wars Clone Wars season 7 episode 1
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay awesome, this is the way!